foreign
cancellation
we turn to the New York Times and a
writer by the name of Jennifer weiner
back in July Miss weiner wrote an
article reflecting on a very important
national issue that Jennifer Lopez had
gotten married to Ben Affleck and taken
his last name I only became aware of
this article because Lopez reacted to it
this week in an interview with Vogue
magazine and as you know I am an Avid
Reader of Vogue magazine before we get
to Lopez's response let's first review
Weiner's piece which is titled why it
matters that JLo is now JF
she writes the second chance romance
leading up to last week's nuptials
between Jennifer Lopez and the actor and
director Ben Affleck was a pandemic gift
that kept on giving for Romantics and
celebrity gossip addicts alike every
chapter of the benefit 2.0 Love Story
gave us something new to chew on the
most recent nugget JLo's decision first
announced in her subscription only on
the J-Lo newsletter to change her last
name
quote love is a great thing maybe the
best of things and worth waiting for She
Wrote signing off with love Miss
Jennifer Lynn Affleck true love wins
except also oof
wiener writes and just so you know
except also oof will be about as
insightful as this essay gets she
continues
Miss Affleck may be surrendering to the
power of love with this her fourth
marriage but given the cringy history
behind the practice a woman taking her
husband's last name feels to me like a
submission a gesture that doesn't say I
belong with him so much as I belong to
him and at this fraught moment for
feminism in America a woman like the
former Jennifer Lopez deciding to change
her name feels especially dispiriting
sure taking your husband's name might be
a way of saying this is for Keeps but
it's also a gesture inextricably rooted
in Peak patriarchy specifically in 11th
century law of coverture which held that
a married woman was for legal purposes
merged with her husband with no standing
or identity of her own that notion hung
on for centuries and still endures in
various forms around the world
now I will not Shock you to learn as
Weiner reveals later in the article that
she herself has been married multiple
times she explains that uh she didn't
take the last name of her in her words
current and final husband
uh it will also not Shock you to learn
that she references the handmaid's tale
writing quote the idea of taking a
husband's last name always made me
uncomfortable reminding me of the
handmaid's tale and Margaret Atwood's
Gilead the ant The handmaids Who exist
to carry the babies of the elites are
stripped of anything that identifies
them as individuals including their
names
as we know if not for Harry Potter and
the handmaid's tale leftist would not be
able to make any literary references at
all just as if not for Hitler they would
be unable to make any historical
references at all
um but in any case weiner goes on for
several more paragraphs explaining what
Jennifer Lopez should have made a
different decision about her own last
name and why her decisions are somehow
relevant to the public indeed she says
Jennifer Lopez's name is whether she
likes it or not a political issue she
concludes
whether or not to take a spouse's name
is a personal decision
but the personal is political now more
than ever and especially for celebrities
like every Star or every Mortal with an
Instagram account Miss Affleck has
constructed a persona for public
consumption she has used her platform to
tell the tale of the upward trajectory
of a strong independent woman a woman
who has gone from backup dancer to
Global Superstar her brand is intense
competence and hardcore self-sufficiency
in control and loving it as she sings in
Jenny From the Block whoever Jennifer
Affleck is in her private life JLo is a
woman who might love a man but doesn't
need one imagine if in her newsletter
she had said I love my husband right now
though women are under attack and I
won't participate in a tradition that's
historically rooted in women
relinquishing their identities and their
legal standing I'm giving my husband my
heart but I'm keeping my name
or imagine if Ben Affleck had become Ben
Lopez
now admittedly I'm sort of surprised
that he didn't go that direction and I'm
also surprised pleasantly slow so by
Jennifer Lopez's response in Vogue this
week
where she offers a defense of family and
of tradition she says reacting to the
New York Times article what really
people are still going to call me
Jennifer Lopez but my legal name will be
Mrs Affleck because we're joined
together her husband and wife I'm proud
of that I don't think that's a problem
and then when asked about the idea of
Ben Affleck becoming Ben Lopez she says
no it's not traditional it doesn't have
any romance to it it feels like it's a
power move you know what I mean I'm very
much in control of my own life and
Destiny and I feel empowered as a woman
as a person I can understand that people
have their feelings about it and that's
okay too but if you want to know how I
feel about it it just feels romantic it
still carries tradition and romance to
me and maybe I'm just that kind of dirt
girl
well well said and now admittedly
Jennifer Lopez has been married
something like 14 times under most
circumstances you would not consider her
to be an advocate or Defender of the
sanctity of marriage and the beauty and
importance of tradition but on this
issue at least she's correct and Miss
weiner in New York Times is like so many
other left-wing feminists uh frivolous
ridiculous spiteful
despising what is traditional simply
because it is traditional without being
able to articulate any reason beyond
that
so there are three points we made here
first
you'll notice how quickly the let women
make their own decisions facade Falls
away as we see time and time again the
feminists left
they respect and value a woman's choice
provided she makes exactly the choice
that they want her to make
if she makes the personal choice they
prefer then it's good that you know she
made a personal choice and they should
respect their choices if she makes the
personal choice they do not prefer
then the personal is political and they
have every right to attack her for it
that's just the way the game is played
second Lopez is correct that sharing a
last name is about Unity it's about
being joined bonded together
the modern enlightened quote-unquote
marriage is one where nothing is shared
separate finances separate names
Separate Lives
and eventually separate houses and
separate divorce lawyers because the
whole point of marriage the reason it
exists is to bring man and woman
together as one that's its beauty it's
mystery it's reason
if you're determined to maintain an
entirely separate identity from your
spouse
then you're really determined to close
yourself off from the true nature and
the greatest joys of the marital Union
now you could say that a last name is
just the last name what does it matter
but but a name is a symbol and symbols
are deeply important and meaningful to
human beings
the choice to share a name is symbolic
as it as discussed
but it symbolizes unity and fidelity
the choice to not share a name is also
symbolic then and what does that
symbolize well the opposite of unity
infidelity one of my favorite Avett
Brothers song called uh murder in the
city says always remember there was
nothing worth sharing like the love that
let us share our name and that's what
that's what it symbolizes man and wife
share a name because of the love that
bonds them together
third Point finally
um
to to Jennifer Lopez's point
tradition does matter
now it may not always be enough to
defend a tradition merely on the basis
that it is a tradition not all
Traditions should continue indefinitely
just because they're traditions
but Traditions matter they tie you to
your ancestors to your heritage to your
past
our ancestors speak to us through
tradition
Traditions are their voice the Democracy
of the dead as Chesterton said
what this means is that if you're going
to tear down a tradition
or get away from one you better have a
very good reason
we may not continue every tradition but
there needs to be a reason to
discontinue it a compelling reason
but because you know even if at first
you you're doing something and you're
and you're saying well why are we doing
this and
the fact that
generations and generations and and and
and for centuries in Millennia before
you people did that thing
that's that's that's like an indication
that there's something worth doing here
and again it's that's not always going
to mean that you should continue it
but to just reflexively say oh we're not
gonna do this anymore
that's the problem and the left reacts
reflexively to tradition only that
reflex is to reject it
it may not always make sense to defend
Traditions merely on the basis that they
are Traditions but it makes even less
sense to attack them merely on the basis
that they are traditions
in the case of marital names the
tradition is good because as we've
already covered it Fosters unity and a
shared purpose and a shared identity
it's also good
because it is a tradition it became a
tradition because it's good and
meaningful
and the fact that it is a tradition only
makes it all the more good and
meaningful
and that ultimately is why the left
wants to dismantle it because they seek
to dismantle everything that is good and
meaningful especially if it's
traditional
and that is why Jennifer weiner not
Lopez is today canceled that'll do it
for this portion of the show as you move
over to the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]